the blm riots last summer caused several
deaths probably a dozen more than a
billion dollars in property damage in
this country most of which has not been
rebuilt in case you've forgotten here's
what they look like
[Applause]
tip
[Music]
[Applause]
that's all been memory hold save it on
your hard drive probably won't be
available soon
but the spirit lives on just days ago a
blm activist called hawk newsom
threatened the newly elected mayor of
new york city eric adams who for the
record is also black but whatever
newsome promised quote riots and
bloodshed
if the new mayor
dares to enforce the law
the existing laws of the city of new
york are going to kill people if you
dare do that
so that's a threat of violence what's
interesting is that merrick garland
who's our attorney general or chief law
enforcement officer hasn't even
acknowledged it
instead he's been targeting parents who
complain about school boards because
they're terrorists
today a doj whistleblower came forward
with evidence that merrick garland has
been using counterterrorism tools to
investigate parents who don't like being
told that they're racist
because you have to sit there and take
it you're racist okay
so counter-terrorism officials created a
so-called threat tag to allow multiple
federal agencies to track parents as if
they were domestic terrorists like
they're isis
so if this is true it would mean it's
time to impeach and prosecute merrick
garland because he just lied under oath
during his recent sworn testimony on
capitol hill mud maren is a lawyer and
parents rights advocate we need a lot
more of those also a former new york
city council candidate joins us now
matt thanks so much uh for coming on
tonight so here you have thank you
tucker a guy threatening the new mayor
of new york with violence if he dares to
enforce the law the justice department
ignores it and spends its time
classifying people like you as al qaeda
what do you make of this
well i was pretty shocked i have to say
when i read the letter um that merrick
garland wrote responding to the national
school board association letter and that
letter from the national school board
association asked the government to
classify parents like me
as domestic terrorists and merrick
garland responded very quickly to that
letter and said that he would take
action that he would create a federal
task force and he doubled down on the
letter that he wrote when he was
testifying before congress
that doubling down and that enthusiasm
for prosecuting parents could not stand
in any stronger opposition to the
silence that we're hearing now
when as you correctly point out
activists who
were rioting last summer in new york
city are now telling our new mayor-elect
that if he implements the policies that
he campaigned on
to get the rising violence in new york
city in check that if he implements
those policies there will be fire riots
and bloodshed that's their words
it's almost like some people in
authority consider lunatics like that
threatening violence like their own
personal militia that they don't
restrain they sort of doing the bidding
of a political party it almost seems
that way
well we heard a lot last summer
while riots were going on in new york
city
in my neighborhood the stores were
broken into and there was broken glass
on the street for days as we bought we
saw stores boarding up their windows
what we saw was a discussion of those
riots as protests there's a big
difference between protests and riots
and everyday parents and the families of
new york city know the difference
well yeah and you can't destroy our
cities not everybody can move to montana
you can't let our biggest city become a
cesspool and so i'm just grateful that
you're you're fighting all of this
momentum i hope you'll come back great
to see you
tonight thank you tucker hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else